[Music]
all right here at news now we have put
out all our reporters to cover the area
where we're seeing damage and we're
seeing flooding because we want to make
sure you are all safe we showed you
shashalaptas now we go to joe mulder
who's now at the arroyo grand sports
complex this is down near sunset station
in henderson joe what are you seeing
yeah we're on a drive over here from the
strip area we saw several street lights
out
around the arroyo grande sports complex
where you're at but
that storm came through here and dropped
a lot of rain it was very windy we just
spoke to some people who were in this
area i'll give you a look
a crew just left here they tore apart
this tree that was uh
knocked over during this strong storm
that moved through this area and you can
throughout this park there's a number of
limbs down even right in front of us
here you can see that throughout the
park and
someone who actually works here just
mentioned over at the softball fields
there's even more trees down and some
damage to the fence but
i want to give you a look at the pitman
wash which is here through the
arroyo grande sports complex you can see
just how much water
is flowing through this sports complex
and through this wash a neighbor came
out here just to see how much water was
going through here and they say
you know what we need the water but they
said they haven't experienced anything
like this in quite some time and i'm
actually going to have our
photojournalist chris
pan across the washer to the dog park
over there it's
actually flooded through there so it's
full of water so you're seeing that
in different areas but on the drive over
here a lot of people driving slow
throughout henderson
santiago and arroyo grande where we are
at people just driving slow at these
stoplights that are completely out so
that is suggested if you are driving in
the areas just keep ahead
eye up for those streetlights that might
be out but we're going to be around this
area to bring the very latest on the
damage that has happened through these
storms
storm cells that have moved through this
area but for now ted i'll send it back
to you
joe thank you very much great job out
there we sent joe there because they
picked up an
inch almost an inch and a half of rain
in less than 45 minutes
so i knew that area that wash would be
just filled up and there it is we want
to remind you
do not go near those washes okay because
there's debris in it
you fall in you can get bit by debris
and be carried off too so avoid
those washes that is the pitman wash
down at the royal grand
down near sunset station currently
outside 91 degrees
for las vegas henderson 87 for nellis 94
for north las vegas
the temperatures drop when you have rain
all across the valley
the numbers drop it cools off we were
talking that with kirsten a couple days
back open your windows because it cools
the atmosphere's cold after rain wind
speeds have calmed down after some very
strong gusts now we talked about
microbursts so i'm going to explain to
you
what a microburst is okay we have that
evaporative cooling we have the
thunderstorm i really want to focus on
the thunderstorm here what this is not
showing you
is the updraft okay so everything goes
all up into the thunderstorms gets
pulled up
it gets heavy gets dense here cooler air
gets heavy
so then it comes crashing down cool air
falls and accelerates all right
big time and that's what you've seen
with those microbursts and not only they
come crashing down the ground
the air gets ground hits the ground and
gets forced and spread outward right
we're talking gus can get up to 150
miles per hour that's why sasha talked
about that they can bring down planes
with these microverse
we see them up to 65 for the day today
they hit the ground they spread out and
that's why you see all these downed
trees everywhere
this is a wet microburst there's dry
microbursts and wet microbursts wet
microbursts bring down the rain with it
and we saw plenty of rain today
someone picked up a microburst of 55
miles per hour
henderson picked up a microburst of 60
miles per hour that's south of 215
and this is where sasha was at all right
microburst near henderson airport about
40 mile per hour winds
strong enough winds to bring down uh
those trees that we saw
here are our rain totals i'm gonna show
you this again in our 6 30 hour too
because you can see
where all these rain tallies came up to
half an inch
three tenths of an inch centennial hills
almost four tenths of an inch there
on the far west side near summerlin west
and some of the west about four
almost four tenths of an inch there
around russell and 215.
there's that one this is where joe's at
uh almost an inch and a half
reporting uh an inch and three tenths is
what we're seeing there
right now most of the storms focusing on
cedar city we have them up in lincoln
county too
just two to the wet one the west of us
in boulder city one in the southwest
just north of sandy valley
high pressure to the east but really
today is not the day that we're really
focusing that's going to bring us
some really scattered storms i'm going
to pinpoint those to you in a second
future cast shows tonight not really big
chances for thunderstorms tonight but
i'm not going to
completely rule it out i think we could
still get chances for
isolated storms or an isolated storm for
this evening so that's part of our
forecast
86 degrees isolated thunderstorms a
possibility with those storms you'll
always get gusty
winds along with them 106 for tomorrow
partly sunny and humid still
and i'm still throwing in slight chances
for isolated storms for
tomorrow too here's your eight day
forecast now remember this
week the conditions are primed for
storms to happen
so slight chances friday saturday now
sunday those storms are going to pick up
even more
monday right now looks like be the
stormy day where we're all going to be
all hands on deck for that
and then tuesday isolated storms also
possible too
and then as we get to the week next week
the monsoon backs off just a little bit
but we're keeping very slight chances
also for next
week too welcome to monsoon 2021